science is not about criticizing science
is about explaining
physics is about explaining phenomena
mechanisms uh you have to explain
causes and you can only explain causes
if you have
physical objects okay so that's a
starting point at least from my point of
view
um is science just criticizing well no
in fact uh
i had a discussion some time back with a
fella and uh he said you know i don't
need to
tell you my theory i can just rationally
logically debunk yours
you know i can show that yours falls
because it lacks merits or rationality
or logic or whatever
i don't need to show you my cards no
that doesn't occur in science that might
be true in a card game
you know some card games you don't have
to show your cards you can
just go to the deck not in science
science you have a conference and a
conference is a dialogue or a
trial or a multi-log everybody who comes
in there
has to present his case okay now why is
that
well imagine guy comes to the conference
he says well i just came here to uh
criticize your theory that's all i want
to do and then i leave
well there's a couple problems with that
the first one is that obviously
even if he's successful right um
he's already got a different way of
thinking the fact that he's
criticizing my theory right or your
theory for that matter
means that he's got a different way of
thinking so why won't he present his
theory
is he afraid that people will laugh at
his theory or
think of it even worse than the one he's
criticizing i mean he could criticize a
point
and he might win that point say okay we
didn't think about that you're right uh
it fails here or we we can't answer it
yet
that could be true the rest of the
theory could be okay for all we care
what do you have to propose in exchange
and the guy says well no i'm not going
to tell you my theory i don't have to
and that doesn't appear in science and
the reason is that the doors are locked
of the conference room they're locked
nobody can get out we can't get out
until we fix
the problem of the universe we need to
figure out how the universe works
and so if my theory or your theory
doesn't work this guy can't come in and
say i
just came here to criticize no no way
you debunked our theories great
ours are destroyed they're no good what
do you have to propose how does the
universe work
and you can't say oh i'm not going to
tell you my theory i just want to leave
no not in science so yeah science is not
about criticizing
science is about proposing it's about
explaining how the universe works
in the case of physics right because as
i put science we have two branches one
is philosophy the other one's physics
philosophy deals with concepts purpose
and reason why someone did something why
did napoleon go to waterloo that's a
scientific question
and people uh you know throw theories
you can say their opinions yeah their
opinion but they're theories one guy
says he went there to steal the other
guy says
he wanted glory you know so everybody's
got his own theory and that's scientific
because they're
giving you an explanation for why
napoleon went to waterloo
physics deals with uh causes mechanisms
and obviously in order to explain it you
have to mediate them with objects
okay and uh so science is about
explaining and we
can't leave the conference room until we
explain how the universe works